so until there was some type of a
regulator or somebody who approves you
know say oh I approve this campaign time
the thing what type of due diligence can
the average Kickstarter browser do on
their own or is there really no way to
truly tell looks legit and what's not
what's what's a real charity what's not
it's hard to tell i think that it's
certain types of projects there are
things that you can do such as you know
puts filmmaker you can look at their
previous works you can see the quality
of the work is you can see if it's gone
to festivals who's in it who the
producers are there's that type of
homework you can do to see whether this
person is legitimate or not that being
said that has no bearing on whether
they'll be able to deliver this current
product and that's something in you know
i donated to short film project and the
director had like amazing credentials
and that's why i donated because i
thought that they would be able to
follow through and they were supposed to
have sent out dvds the film was
completed they were supposed to send out
dvds in many and there has not been a
single update on this project since May
and I think again this is the case of
the filmmaker like having some kind of
problem and not wanting to tell people
about it but the longer it goes without
them communicating the more people are
like what are you doing and getting
upset and that makes me more hesitant to
donate to the next short film project
then again you know you have to kind of
view it
mentality of the year if you know you're
giving an average donation which tends
to be between 25 and fifty dollars you
know you're putting it out there in the
hopes you're going to get something back
but you have to be realistic and the
fact that people don't deliver and
that's a risk that you are taking when
you decide to give your money away you
know I I think that just like anything
else any other business arrangement you
go into you can search you know look up
people online and do that kind of thing
you can also ask them questions I mean
Kickstarter is a lot about the personal
connection if you are concerned that
their goal is not high enough to really
create the product you can message them
and say okay you have any other funding
sources or something like that because a
lot of people do a lot of people on
Kickstarter do have other funding
sources outside the Kickstarter and
things like that and do your own
homework and if you don't trust the
answers that you're getting you
shouldn't you know that that project
I mean you're not obligated to sponsor
somebody else's thing and I think you
know it comes down to voting with your
dollar and as more people view it that
way it's going to be the more legitimate
projects that rise to the top but then
again the Creator could get hit by a bus
you know there's there's no guarantees
there's and I don't think that you know
it may be hard for it to continue to
work the way that it works now if there
are guarantees put in place
you